bonsoir nous sommes le mardi à 6
septembre merci de nous retrouver et
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition a
dû séduit-elle les invités du lundi au
jeudi nous recevons et nous donnons la
parole à ceux qui font l'actualité
aujourd'hui au programme de témoignages
et un entretien dominique tristan
directeur de la ferme de grille nous
nous parle du lait d'île de france un
partenariat est coresponsable avec deux
autres fermes des yvelines et une
possible solution à la crise des
agriculteurs laitiers rencontre
également sport avec jean pierre heuzé
le nouveau président de l'entente
athlétique de saint quentin en yvelines
et enfin les cris devient un critère est
très sélectif pour les étudiants mais
aussi en entreprise c'est un sujet
d'actualité en ces temps de rentrée
scolaire mathilde obino et blogueuse
écrivain et professeur elle a coécrit un
livre écriture est stratégique et viens
nous en parler bonsoir à mathilde merci
de nous retrouver alors voilà comme je
viens de le dire vous êtes écrivain
professeur et vous tenez un blog la saga
des audacieux vous êtes ici pour nous
parler de ce livre écriture stratégiques
alors c'est un livre conseils pratiques
comment vous l'avez écrit et qu'est ce
qui vous a donné envie de l'écrire alors
les deux à la fin on a été quatre
professeurs à l'écrire et l'idée c'était
de proposer des conseils justement pour
les étudiants qui rendent dans l'univers
l'entreprise mais aussi pour les
managers pour les accompagner au mieux
en mettant en avant l'importance de
l'écriture aujourd'hui pour l'univers
l'entreprise alors vous avez constaté
parce que des étudiants c'est la scam
gestion qui vont faire un certain nombre
d'années d'études des lacunes au niveau
de l'écrit alors ce en les préparant au
celsa justement leur donnant les
possibilités de réussir au mieux et en
effet en parfois en corrigeant des
copies on leur donne des petits trucs et
astuces pour pouvoir être sensible aux
grains des mots et pouvoir justement
grâce à la sémantique grâce à la
grammaire arriver à se démarquer à une
j'ai par rapport aux autres candidats
est ce que selon d'un perdu un peu le
sens de l'écriture peut-être à cause des
ordinateurs à cause des smartphones à
cause des technologies oui bah c'est
dévaloriser aujourd'hui on a
l'impression c'est le règne de l'image
en l'écrit est très important et ça il
faut le remettre à l'ordre du jour alors
les conseils pratiques que l'on doit
absolument retenir pour ce livre qui ne
s'adresse pas aux étudiants mais aussi
peut-être aux jeunes actifs aux gens qui
sont dans l'entreprise depuis longtemps
oui alors à la fin on reprend des points
de grammaire de syntaxe et puis aussi
des conseils pour bien écrire un mail
comment être présent sur les réseaux
sociaux voilà tout ça puisse servir la
cohérence justement d'un parcours et
puis aussi pour les entrepreneurs pour
construire une carrière alors justement
peut-être les erreurs qu'on fait le plus
souvent quand on écrit des mails quelles
sont elles des erreurs d'inattention
aussi des fautes on va le dire bonjour
monsieur on va dire bonjour madame c'est
des petites erreurs qui feront la
différence et finalement qui va être un
blocage pour l'interlocuteur les erreurs
de syntaxe qu'il faut absolument éviter
les fonds va reprendre lé foot basiques
les accords les pluriels bien rouler
bien veillé à relire ses phrases que ça
soit très cohérent aussi les conseils
voilà sont des conseils pratiques et
est-ce que voilà en entreprise il ya un
drame aussi des choses auxquelles il
faut penser au delà des mails ou de la
tête qu'on fait des rapports des comptes
rendus c'est ça aussi ça peut nous
dévaloriser oui faut bien veiller à
construire ses phrases avec un message
clair et ça c'est important et être
sensible à son interlocuteur à qui je
m'adresse est ce que c'est une
communication interne est-ce que c'est à
des parties prenantes à extérieur est ce
que c'est des clients est toujours
ajuster son discours pour que ça soit le
mieux reçus possible alors vous faites
aussi votre blog la saga des audacieux
que vous tenez est-ce que vous avez des
nouveautés justement à ce propos est-ce
qu'il ya peut-être des personnalités
qu'on va découvrir sur ce blog qui vont
nous inspirer pour la rentrée oui nous
toujours avec cette idée de mettre en
avant des leaders qui incarne l'audace
l'innovation
j'ai par exemple interrogé au roi nominé
qui a fondé une start up qui s'appelle
ecotri donc tournée vers le
développement durable je suis allé chez
havas pour rencontrer et découvrir un
canapé qui s'appelle marthien canapé
connectés donc beaucoup d'innovations et
et voilà mettre en avant de dédier les
gens et qui aussi des politiques dans
cette année présidentielle alors cette
professeur écrivain
blogueuse c'est pas trop dur de mener sa
de tous les fronts en fait tous ses
activités en même temps on va c'est
passionnant parce qu'à chaque fois c'est
des univers qui sont finalement assez
liés les uns aux autres et puis on
apprend chaque fois on découvre donc
c'est toujours très intéressant alors je
le rappelle écriture stratégique donc
c'est un livre qui est publié à chea
studyrama dans la collection principe et
voilà ça s'adresse aux étudiants qui
préparent les grandes écoles mais aussi
à toutes les personnes dans le monde
entreprises et qui souhaitent ne plus
faire de faute il est question à
d'agriculture à présent le lait d'île de
france a été officiellement lancé la
semaine dernière un partenariat entre
trois fermes yvelinoise la ferme de
viltain elle est à jouy en josas la
ferme de grignon hâtive ravalait grignon
la ferme de bissy à bonnel une laiterie
est un distributeur de la région et tout
cela va être distribué dans 237 points
de la région en ile de france une
initiative pour tenter d'apporter une
réponse à la crise du lait je vous
proposais d' écouter dominique et
tristan il est directeur de la ferme de
grignon nous en dit plus nous sommes
trois producteurs dans les yvelines va
ferme de gueugnon la ferme de bissy la
ferme de viltain qui travaillons
ensemble depuis un certain nombre
d'années déjà et
observant les difficultés que nous avons
sur la vente de notre lait et
parallèlement à ça les franciliens
plutôt amateurs de produits locaux
vu que ce qu'on produit c'est une toute
petite partie de la consommation de lait
français franciliens pardon je vais y
arriver mais en fait on se dit voilà
essayons de
transformer un lettre à ses issues de
nos fermes donc nous avons rencontré
l'actrice anny l'hôtel qui s'est aussi
spécialisé sur des petits volumes de
lait avec un outil industriel tout de
même qui n'est pas mais d'avoir des
coûts de production
raisonnable et puis nous sommes partis
sur le printemps sur cette discussion
est avec l'aboutissement final avec le
contrat avec intermarché qui nous a
permis d'investir dans le packaging et
de lancer le produit disponible depuis
début juillet chez intermarché en
exclusivité pour trois mois on à l'ars
historique entre les trois fermes
justement pour vendre en commun notre
lait depuis des dizaines d'années je
dirais donc on était déjà un petit peu
rodé à ce
complexité logistique parce qu'il ya une
vraie complicité derrière de régularité
de chargements de camions de camions
complets ça paraît tout bête mais voilà
donc ça s'est fait assez naturellement
finalement chez nous et c'était aussi un
argument pour lancer le projet puisque
ça sécurisait et l'industriel sur le
fait qu'il ait des camions remplis le
bonjour la bonne date et derrière
intermarché d'avoir quand il passe la
commande qu'il est le produit qui arrive
alors bon on n'est pas totalement film
3par donc on veut gagner de l'argent à
travers la vente de nos produits ce qui
est sexe qui est clair c'est qu'à
l'instant t aujourd'hui le prix du lait
n'est clairement pas rémunérateur on
perd de l'argent donc on est sur des
systèmes ou avec la moins deux salariés
donc voilà ça très très compliqué en ce
moment les trésoreries sont plus bas
donc voilà on va déjà repartir sur une
boucle vertueuse pouvoir investir payer
nos jouant mieux les payer
la base ensuite c'est vrai que c'est
aussi une vision pour nous d'aller
jusqu'au bout c'est à dire que on se
contente pas de produire du lait de
mètres dans le temps que dans le tank de
l'est et que lunetterie qu'elle convient
que cherchait le télé et puis on est
dans une démarche globale où on est
impliqué voilà jusqu'au bout y compris
dans la mise en avant du produit on va
tous faire on en est déjà fait
d'ailleurs des animations commerciales
dans les magasins pour expliquer
l'histoire qui lie à autour de la brique
de lait est un des points forts aussi
c'est que nos fermes sont ouvertes au
public donc les gens peuvent venir
vérifier que ce qu'on écrit sur la
brique de lait c'est une réalité de tous
les jours et on va parler sport
maintenant et plus précisément
d'athlétisme il ya du changement à la
tête de l'entente athlétique de saint
quentin en yvelines le club qui compte
plus de 800 adhérents est désormais
présidée par jean pierre heuzé il a 28
ans le sportif était au club depuis
septembre 2010 il remplace max vignes et
qui dirigeait la structure depuis 2003
on écoute le nouveau président c'est une
interview menée par michael minéraux
voilà en fait moi je suis arrivé au club
en septembre 2010
j'ai dû faire un an ou deux où je
m'entraînais vraiment après j'ai eu des
problèmes de blessures récurrentes aux
deux mollets ce qui fait que j'avais un
peu plus de temps avec les blessures et
comme j'ai toujours aimé être sur le
stade j'ai commencé à proposer mon aide
au club pour pour donner un coup demain
s'il a besoin de moi c'est comme ça que
je suis rentré au sein du bureau et peu
de temps après il y avait les les
vice-présidents en fait qui qui n'avait
plus le temps et donc qui souhaitait
arrêter et un dessin des projets du club
c'était un peu le renouvellement scinder
à dire des bénévoles pour essayer d'en
profiter d' essayer d'avoir un peu de
jeunesse pour se préparer les
transitions pour les années à venir donc
c'est comme ça que j'ai été élu vice
président et d'un autre côté max avec
son son travail
et pour d'autres d'autres raisons avait
beaucoup moins de possibilités d'être
sur le terrain sur les heurts des années
c'était compliqué pour lui et donc il
essaie de suivre un peu tout ce qui est
finalement pour la gestion du club à
participer autant qu'ils pouvaient mais
quand on est moins sur le terrain c'est
pas toujours toujours évident qu'en fait
il avait souhaité ces dernières années
passées le passé le relais alors ça a
mis un peu de temps parce que moi je
n'avais pas forcément le temps et cette
année en fait je
après bras après quelques discussions
même avec ma femme m'a aussi à côté j'ai
proposé de passer président pour le
remplacer sachant que lui rester vice
président pour pouvoir m'épauler parce
que ça fait pas non plus si longtemps
que je suis je suis au club et je
découvre au fur et à mesure j'apprends
donc il est là aussi pour m'aider pour
pour bien réussir à prendre ces tâches
correctement et quels sont vos objectifs
pour ce club
alors pour ce club c'est
quand je dis comme on a pas mal de
turnover au niveau des des animateurs
des jeunes et sachant que c'est la base
au niveau de l'apprentissage pour pour
essayer en fait de les former et les
faire atteindre leur niveau au niveau
maximum pour de l'opo de leur potentiel
donc certains atteindront l'équipe de
france donc peut-être championnat
championnat de france d'autres
championnats d'île de france tout le
monde n'a pas les mêmes poteau même
potentiel il a même pas je dirais pas la
même envie mais souvent l'envié est là
mais pas la même le même temps libre
pour pouvoir pratiquer ce sport et
finalement nous on est là pour leur
donner leur permettre de donner leur
maximum et faut les former dès le plus
jeune âge donc là c'est d'arriver à
retrouver un projet au niveau de
certaines stabilité au niveau de la
formation chez chez les jeunes pour
qu'on ait de nouvelles pousses qui
sortent et qu'ils puissent éclore après
quand il arrive au lycée université pour
vraiment percé par la suite quoi c'est
la fin du set 8 invités merci de nous
avoir suivis rendez vous à chaque soir à
18h15 du lundi au jeudi pour une
nouvelle édition les programmes se
poursuivre sur notre antenne à rester
avec nous